hi my name is jillian and i am a senior
aquarist at georgia aquarium
and i'm here in our sharks predators of
the deep gallery and i will be answering
your most googled shark questions
so our first question is can sharks be
trained well
most animals can be trained if you have
the right reinforcement
so what we use here at georgia aquarium
is called positive reinforcement
where we reward the desired behavior and
simply ignore
undesired behavior and depending on the
species sharks can be trained to either
come to a specific location and feed off
tongs
or like our zebra sharks here they can
be trained to do more advanced behaviors
like resting on guest laps the sharks
really attack humans
so the likelihood of you getting
attacked by a shark is extremely
rare in 2020 there were only 57
unprovoked shark attacks
worldwide but if you do happen to get
bit by a shark
it's usually for a couple reasons one is
mistaken identity
the shark simply thinks you're a prey
item it might be murky
visibility conditions they can't see you
properly
the second is they're defending a
territory third
you might actually scare a shark we are
kind of big and sometimes they do get
frightened
and lastly they don't have hands to
explore their world so instead they're
using their mouse
and that can result in an exploratory
bite
can shark sense blood well sharks have a
very keen sense of smell so they
absolutely can smell blood in the water
now if you happen to be bleeding in the
water that doesn't mean that sharks are
immediately going to come over to you
we are not their natural prey items do
sharks lay eggs
so sharks have several means of
reproduction but they fall under two
main categories
so the first is egg laying where an
embryo will develop
inside this tough leathery case that's
externally laid by the mother
and once she deposits eggs on the ocean
bottom she kind of leaves them
then we have our sharks that are live
bearings so what that means is the
embryo is retained
inside the uterus of the mother for its
entire period of development
and then she gives birth to live young
do sharks really die if they stop
swimming
in order to breeze sharks have to move
water over their gills so that they can
pull
oxygen out of the water and for gas
exchange to occur
now some sharks have the ability to
actively pump water over their gills
using their mouth so a lot of your
bottom dwelling species like our zebra
sharks here
can actually sit on the bottom not
really moving and they're able to pump
water over their gills and they breathe
totally fine
now other species like our hammerheads
they can't do that they don't have that
ability
so instead they do have to continuously
keep moving
in a forward direction they usually have
their mouth open just a little bit
so that water can flow over those gills
and gas exchange can take place
how and when do sharks sleep so this is
a fascinating question and it's
something that we're still
investigating so we know that sharks
definitely undergo a rest period where
they have decreased motor activity
and response to stimuli and there's lots
of bottom dwelling sharks that can sit
on the ocean bottom motionless
with their eyelids halfway closed in a
sleep-like state
what's really interesting is when we
talk about those sharks that have to
continuously keep swimming so there's
three ideas on how they sleep
one is that they shut down one part of
their brain and keep the other part
active
much like your tooth whales like a sperm
whale the second
is they pretty much allow their entire
brain to sleep
and then ride ocean currents and allow
water to pass over their gills with
their mouth gaping open
and then the last theory is that they're
shutting down most of their brain
except for those few pathways that
control tail movement which allows them
to keep swimming
what types of animals do sharks eat
sharks eat an array of animals and it's
usually dependent on the habitat in
which they live
as well as the shape of their teeth so
for example
some sharks only eat really small
invertebrates in the sand like sea
urchins crabs
shrimps others like our sand tigers they
eat primarily fish
and then you have some sharks like tiger
sharks that eat birds mammals sea
turtles
even other large sharks how fast do
sharks swim
again this depends on the species some
sharks swim rather slow like our zebra
sharks and others like the short fin
mako which is one of the fastest fish
can clock up to speeds of 43 miles per
hour
where did the most dangerous sharks live
according to the international shark
attack file
the most unprovoked attacks occur
firstly in the u.s
than in australia then in the republic
of south africa
what should you do if you encounter a
shark in the ocean
you just want to remain calm the best
thing to do is avoid a lot of splashing
slowly make your way out of the water
and ideally you want to keep your eyes
on the shark the whole time
what is the largest shark the largest
shark as well as the largest fish
is the whale shark which we do have here
at georgia aquarium and they can reach
lengths up to 40 feet long
sharks are very vital to our ecosystems
and they do keep our oceans healthy
so if you'd like to get up close and
personal to sharks you can join us here
at georgia aquarium in our shark and ray
immersion
or if you're feeling a little
adventurous you can join us in our cage
dive program
for more information or if you wish to
donate to our global conservation and
research efforts
you can visit us at georgiaaquarium.org
[Music]